que vois-je un téléphone mais à qui
appartient-il bien le bonjour apprentis
inspecteurs aujourd'hui nous allons
devoir résoudre une terrible énigmes à
qui appartient ce téléphone que je viens
de trouver est ce que cette personne va
bien vous venez de trouver un téléphone
découvrez la vérité parfois la vérité
est sous nos yeux mais on ne la voit pas
au tessin il est 22 heures du soir né le
31 janvier et n'a reçu qu'un nouveau
message ok te papa oui tu passais il
envoyait sa à 21h34 patrick mieux plus
tard il renvoie un message et il dit on
est tous vraiment inquiet dit nous que
tout va bien
ta mère veut appeler la police papa doc
c'était il ya deux minutes seulement
qu'il a reçu ce message si je remonte à
des fois j'ai répondu c'était à 10h37 du
matin [ __ ] joyeux anniversaire mon
fils je suis tellement fière de l'homme
que tu es devenu on fêtera ses animaux
ce soir mais soit préparé une grosse
surprise pour ses 18 ans papa je suppose
donc qu'il avait rendez-vous à 20 heures
à la maison pour fêter son anniversaire
avec ses amis ça c'était indécent donc
ça c'était il ya deux mois malgré savoir
si mélissa vient dîner ce soir à la
maison non on n'est pas vraiment mon
terme en ce moment où on a tous connu
sert également
tu sais il fut un temps où il y avait
une inspectrice quizy je les tue ou le
30 janvier il lui dit je lance un ferry
cause pour la soirée de demain je vais
demander combien on sera est-ce que
mélissa sera là papin et le gamin qu'on
va appeler paul a répondu non mais s'il
te plaît arrête de me demander ça ok
clairement elle a largué et ils
n'arrivent pas à s'en mettre clairement
escape à la meuf mélissa
abstrait salles à partir de quel moment
ça a merdé entre mélissa a aidé sa
grand-mère a déménagé apparemment au
[ __ ] la tambouille à l'attendre
ouyahia qu'est ce qu'on déteste c'est
dans cette situation les gars tu as fait
qu'aujourd'hui je suis allé jouer à des
jeux de société avec qui robert anne
martin il n'y avait pas aller si bas
pourquoi tu mens alors jetez pas montée
j'étais juste pas dit qu'elle était là à
ça c'est la pire phase de merde et dj
votre mug elle va ce veinard direct
pourquoi tu m'as pas dit dès le départ
qu'à lice étaient là tu me cache quelque
chose c'est ça parce que justement dès
que je pars d'alice tu fait une crise de
jalousie je t'ai déjà répété mille fois
cali c'était juste une amie mais c'est
ma meilleure amie je ne compte pas
arrêter de la voir il faut vraiment que
tu arrêtes de me mettre la pression à ce
sujet aux îles à orthez c'est beau je
m'engage les a posés comme ça et là pas
l'art de mentir mais bon dans le doute
ça peut être sa maîtresse et je parle
pas de celle que tu as vu cet après-midi
at-on écoles de kersaux soir dans le sud
est mais j'ai juste besoin d'être
assurés temps en temps tu sais je n'ai
jamais connu des médiums femme avant toi
et alice tu es la seule ou que j'aime
ouais on connaît bien ça n'empêche je
suis sûr que je serai moins jaloux si tu
me la présentez un jour ne t'inquiète
pas ça arrivera tam a fait méga jalouse
de ta meilleure amie
le meilleur moyen pour peu qu'elle soit
jalouse c'est que tu lui présente donc
on vient d'assister à une petite dispute
anodine entre deux jeunes gens d'un
jeune couple
rien d'alarmant le 24 décembre à lui dit
je suis à l'aéroport je pense à toi on
se revoit un nouvel an il lui dit
passent de bonnes vacances
non ne me dis pas qu'ils aient vu la
mort et de vacances qui a tout pété et
six jours plus tard lui envoie un
message pour lui dire qu'il me manque
c'est et lyon cette semaine de vacances
en te voir je parie que tu en a profité
pour voir alice en plus ce à quoi elle a
bien su répondre oui j'ai vu une ou deux
fois mais c'est la meilleure cote a pas
à s'inquiéter mais non je ne les ai pas
vu je n'ai pensé qu'à toi toute la
semaine
hâte d'être demain et donc le lendemain
j'ai prévu une grosse surprise pour ce
soir quelque chose pour vraiment
célébrer l'arrivée de la nouvelle année
avec un clin d'oeil
allez je t'envoie un indice en photos de
la lingerie sexy qu'est-ce qui a pu
forer labeaume avait appelé la n'a pas
enquêté l'a voulu je me foute le sommes
par rapport à ma vie sentimentale c'est
ça je suis désolé mais je ne viendrai
pas je sais que tu espérais beaucoup de
choses pour ce soir mais il est temps de
l'admettre on en est vraiment un stade
différent nos vies on n'a plus les mêmes
attentes on est plus les ados d'autres
fois je me rends compte à quel point
c'est horrible de te dire ça comme ça je
te souhaite de passer une bonne soirée
tout de même et de trouver ton bonheur
en 2016 mon instinct d'enquêteurs me dis
que quelqu'un lui a mis la pression pour
qu'ils quittent melissa m attends tu
rigoles tu me quittes c'est quoi ce
délire tout se passait bien jusqu'à
maintenant il s'est passé quelque chose
pendant les vacances tous ne peuvent
habiter on s'aime il ne s'est rien passé
pendant les vacances j'ai juste
l'impression de ne plus ressentir la
même chose
attends tu ne vas pas casser toute notre
relation sur un coup de tête vient la
maison par l'onda en face plutôt
l'abattant dont ma décision est prise et
j'ai envie de passer la soirée sol
désolé va te faire [ __ ] réponses
correctes je sais que ça paraît vraiment
content de dire tout ça maintenant mais
je suis vraiment désolé pour tous qui
sait pas c'est une personne vraiment
génial et tu mérite plus qu'un connard
comme moi ça m'énerve ça c'est la faute
du mak assume pas mérite mieux c'est
pour ça que je te quitte c'est vraiment
pas parce qu' allissa des gros seins et
j'adore ça mais c'est du moins ce que je
peux faire pour t'aider à aller mieux
demande moi ce que tu veux tu sais que
j'ai déplacé des montagnes pour toi je
te veux toi tu es tu as toujours été
l'unique personne que je voulais dans ma
vie tout sauf ça si je peux faire quoi
que ce soit d'autre pour faire pardonner
ou t'aider à lait bio dis-le moi je ne
plus jamais entendre parler toi s'il te
plaît ne m'écrit plus ne viens pas me
parler à l'école et évite moi tu es
toxiques ça me tue la pire chose qui me
soit arrivée au quai inspections sur sa
conversation avec alice c'est une très
grande prestation je vais inspectés pour
vous
oh [ __ ] bon alice est célibataire
allen copine qui est en couple avec un
mec et cette copine est extrêmement
jalouse vous avez deux semaines ça me
répond que sa copine à lui mais du ca
est aussi très jalouse c'est la calice
scène réponse plutôt triste tu as une
copine je ne savais pas une minute de
silence pour alice bon track une seconde
oui j'avoue pardon de n'avoir jamais
parlé mec tu mettais une petite option
sur alice avons eu c'est cool je suis
juste un peu surprise je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai toujours pensé que j'étais
plutôt à fond sur les garçons ah ça
c'est lui attendu à gevrey a égalisé à
l'été dec parce qu'elle était un petit
peu sur sam mais pas du tout il croit
qu'il était totalement homosexuel je
crois que j'aime les deux je ne sais pas
trop encore mais garde le pour toi quoi
mais attends avait arrêté les
rebondissements là il a peut-être
rencontré un mec c'est pour ça qu'il a
quitté maëlys invite à mon gars mais ce
téléphone qu'on a trouvé c'est un brave
gars exceptionnel où j'ai trouvé un
message intéressant le 6 janvier il a
envoyé un message à alice alice il faut
vraiment que je te parle un truc grave
sa peau mélissa j'ai besoin de te parler
répond répond répondent ils sont donné
rendez vous dans un parc pour parler du
thym du coup y'a pas de trace de ce
qu'ils ont pu se dire le soir alice lui
dit je serai toujours là pour toi même
si je dois avouer que j'ai été surprise
par ta grosse confection sache que tu
peux toujours compter sur moi c'est quoi
cette grosse confiance et ça c'est sale
élément clé de l'enquète le 31 janvier
indice lui envoie un message pour lui
souhaiter joyeux anniversaire 18 ans est
un homme à la barbe tout ça et ça me
ludique la soirée vient de commencer
comme je craignais c'est bien naze il
était donc à 19h46 et à cette [ __ ] de
soirée il y était à 19h46 mai à 20h15
son père le chercher il est donc parti
entre 19 46 et 20h15 ensuite alice leurs
proches de donner trop d'importance aux
dates et que maintenant c'est un homme
extracteur et là il ya un brouillon
merci pour tes conseils mais tu sais je
n'accorde pas tant d'importance que ça
aux dates je te laisse on reproche
d'avoir le nez collé au téléphone au
lieu de profiter de la soirée puis mon
père s'apprête à souffrir son grand
cadeau surprise vous l'aurez compris
c'est donc cette photo son daron avec la
moto surprise il se met bien que vous
internautes auraient dû début a été bien
nul à chier avec la con tre soir et tout
noter surtout pas ça dans vos cahiers
donc il a pris la moto
il est parti et n'est jamais revenu donc
soyez un accident soit il s'est rendu
quelque part on ne sait pas où il est
peut-être allé voir mélissa il s'est mis
à l'eau ce beurre d'application de
rencontre le 18 janvier donc je pense
que le code ça va être 18 01
j'ai regardé le calendrier c'est les
mêmes choses qui reviennent chaque
semaine sauf le festival de bd le 19
décembre
nani a fait la marque est en mode
ricains le mois avant le jour tâche
programme est inspecteur aux états unis
ça c'est clair
autre façon de plus en plus populeux
courte description je suis une fille
gentille de 18 ans aux yeux bleus mais
tu es un homme ça je n'ai pas de photo
de moi car je ne me sens pas vraiment
les avec mon physique mais peut-être que
je partagerai une un jour n'y a pas de
montée est homosexuel mince qui tourne
qu'homosexuel sinon la tua décevoir des
mecs à l'évêque était en équipe ans
tombé sur la femme de leur vie
déçu alors lire mes messages presque à
m'intéresser c'est le dernier c'était le
28 janvier il a beaucoup discuté que
sato donc samedi à cet homme j'ai
vraiment aimé ton profil à partir du
parler ouvertement du fait que tu était
bisexuel et que tu te battais contre
toute forme de discrimination à savoir
les francophones james ils ont tous les
deux se dire que c'est des hommes il y
aura pas de doux il ya donc une semaine
plus tard fils envoi sms à sam et le
savent comment vas tu sais comment que
la famille salut fiche débattre maurage
davoust est vraiment pas top avec ma
famille ah bon qu'est ce qui s'est passé
on va dire que je vais une famille assez
conservatrice pas super au vert sur les
questions lgbt tu vois ce que je veux
dire ouais carrément tu as tenté de
faire tout comme garde tout ça s'est mal
passé au nom avec eux ce n'est même pas
la peine d'essayer je sais qu'il me
mettrai à l'apport direct c'est quoi ce
délire de renier son enfant parce qu'il
n'a pas la même orientation sexuelle que
toi au labo free aïssa crains tu crois
que ça les dérange d'autant que ça que
leur fille soit bisexuel
oh ça je ne sais pas ça passerait
peut-être mais je ne pense pas qu'ils
acceptent facilement l'idée que leur
fils soit en fait une fille peut être
bisexuelle as tu un transsexuel c'est
pour ça que dans sa bio elle se décrit
comme une fille donc ensuite fils lui
dit qu'il connaît aussi les transsexuels
du coup saab lui poser question sera
comment ça se passe dans leur vie
élections par exemple qu'il a un copain
ou des gens apprennent qu'ils les
transilien le voir et lui demander du
coup pour le sexe ça se passe comment ce
n'est pas le genre de question qu'il
demanderait une personne que tu connais
à peine pourtant dès que les gens savent
que la personne en face et des
transsexuels ils se permettent toutes
mes tonnes par semaine explique son
mal-être autour de ça qui peut pas en
parler à grand monde et qu'il a peur que
sa mère fouilles sa chambre et tombe sur
son téléphone et donc sur des trucs
sensible fille lui dit qu'il a une
solution pour ça une application qui
s'appelle calculatrice qui ressemble à
une vraie calculatrice les sushis
taparko de dans un camp suite ta mère et
qu'ensuite tu tapes légal s'est offert
un dossier caché où tu peux ranger tes
trucs sensible ma meilleure amie alice
le cje peinture lui faire confiance
c'est bon d'entendre parlement un peu
d'avis je laime déjà je les rencontre et
a pas longtemps au club de société où
j'allais tous les dimanches le truc
c'est j allais en tant que fille en tant
que samantha je portais même une
perruque moi mais c'est super courageux
je suis content que tu es osé le faire
plus un film merci enfin s'est pas passé
exactement comme prévu au final une
salle [ __ ] on est rendu compte elle
menace de le dire aux autres si je
retourne là bas je n'y vais plus je
comprends pas ça il ya des gens ils ont
satisfaction à faire chier les autres
s'est il fait ce qu'il veut ce tuer avec
une perruque suivi à la poêle il y va
pas de butin s'cusez moi je m'énerve je
me transforme en un gris squeeze là sa
part qu'on va devoir trouver le code de
la calculatrice jallet c'est tout l'état
du calendrier c'est pas ça il reste ce
truc météo il ya un code barre lyall et
code postal c'est ça c'est sûr journal
intime
on va enfin apprendre ce qu'il a dit à
alice quand elle a vu au parc [ __ ]
donc il est allé à des réunions du
groupe de soutien pour les ados lgbt il
a expliqué à son de soutien qu'il
adorait le club de jeux de société parce
que c'est le seul endroit où il se sent
femme mais qu'en même temps ils sont
jamais douté de rien parce qu'ils savent
pas que c'est un homme
il y va avec sa perruque il se rappelait
samantha et raille un peu sa voix et se
maquiller mais une jupe et un peu shop
et il n'y voit que du feu
au début il avait prôné la super mais le
fait qu'il soit rendu compte de rien ça
là
vraiment mise en confiance et très bien
donc mélissa n'est pas au courant que
son copain est un transsexuel
mais qui peut pas présenter à alyssa
samantha parce que je d'alice il est
samantha et aux yeux de mélissa il est
samuel justin j'avoue c'est pas du tout
simple comme situation au [ __ ] la mer
le mec de lola qui va au groupe de
jeunes sociétés il va aussi dans la même
école que sam
du coup il a vu sa main droite samuel et
savent en mode samantha il a tout diallo
la lula a demandé des explications ça
lui a tout expliqué et c'est là que le
real a menacé lui a dit de plus jamais
mettre les pieds dans ce groupe de jeu
le 20 décembre il est allé à la transe
prayoga festival pour ton sexuelles avec
le groupe de soutien pour lgbt et s'y
est senti super bien ensuite il parle de
l'anniversaire de son père où ses
parents et mélissa ont débattu sur
l'adoption par les couples homosexuels
c'est là qu'il a appris que mélissa sa
copine était aussi peu ouverte sur le
sujet que ses parents son père est
carrément maussade en fête le 31
décembre donc le soir où il a quitté
mélissa et pensait que c'était une
soirée tranquille qui allait de toute
façon être fatigué à cause de son vol
retour mais apparemment pas du tout elle
avait même prévu de sortir le grand jeu
ce soir elle qui m'avait toujours dit
qu'elle voulait attendre le mariage d'un
coup elle envoie une photo de lingerie
qu'elle prévoyait de porter ce soir mais
n'ont pas moyens je ne me sentais juste
pas capable non c'est pour ça qu'il a
quitté le 6 janvier la mère de mélissa
belles âmes et lui dit que mélissa
fetori de suicide le soir du nouvel an à
ces horribles
c'est donc ça que ça m'a raconté alice
quoi ils ont passé l'après midi au parc
ensemble ensuite sont donc s'attendre
son cousin sont venus passer le week-end
à la maison ils ont critiqué parce qu'il
suit pas l'actualité sportive
lol j'avais une envie de tout le
week-end c'était me barry de partir à
cologna inconvénient c'est la ville où
il est allé à la transe pride le 28
janvier je n'en peux plus j'ai tout
j'aimerais voir le groupe lgbt mais ils
sont fermés à cause de l'incendié
ah oui à des fils de [ __ ] d'homophobe
qui ont foutu le feu au centre mais ça
ne plus entendre parler de moi mes
parents sont chiants les produits c'est
son chien je ne joue plus au jeu de
société j'en peux plus à pita n'y a plus
un seul endroit et peut s'en tirer a
bien cru y est lui-même quoi et fille
lui a parlé des centres lgbt qui
accueille des jeunes qui ne peuvent plus
vivre chez leurs parents et le plus près
et à cologne 1 messieurs l'enquêté close
aussitôt il a eu sa moto aussitôt il a
foncé à cologna pour enfin être qu' il
est enfin s'assumer et enfin être
entouré de gens qui le comprennent mais
un jouet gamin oui oh [ __ ] c'est une
tuerie ce jour 19 la villa douce vous a
plu vous jacques est 600 fois déjà c'est
une super belle histoire c'est très
touchant et c'est d'autant plus touchant
que je suis sûr que ça arrive tous les
jours dans la vraie vie des gens qui
sont pas à leur place qui peuvent pas
assumer à cause des autres mais c'est
pas forcément liées à l'orientation
sexuelle ça peut carrément autre chose
un mec a une passion à et les autres
comprennent pas cette passion et ironie
ça franchement en vrai qu'une personne
soit lesbienne gay bi ou transsexuelles
ce qu'on a pas rien à [ __ ] mais si les
gens font ce qu'ils veulent plus tard
fois ça t'embête et suisses et les
conséquences négatives sur ta liste non
pas du game 1
surtout jamot pas que vous soyez hétéro
lesbiennes gays transsexuels by ben je
vous kiffe vous faites ce que vous
voulez votre cul et vos parties
génitales ça ne me regarde pas à celle
de salma et je vous dis à très
prochainement personnes ont regardé
faites l'amour pas la guerre n'a jamais
été aussi bon de le rappeler